[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host steve steven who the who the
hell is stephen worked for you for like
a year mate did a lot of the edits
stephen eh yeah well what i want to talk
about is all the upcoming projects that
are confirmed and rumored to be in the
works what we're going to do is go
through them all one by one and let you
know what is on the horizon and when we
can expect them so without further ado
let's split them right up the middle
just like wanda did captain carter in
the confirmed and rumored projects
because i can do this all day you're
some of a [ __ ] the first upcoming film
is black panther wakanda forever slated
for an 11th november release later this
year obviously the big thing hanging
over this movie is the loss of chadwick
bozeman in the iconic role and i'm
really interested to see how they handle
this whole situation it's of course a
massive loss to the comic book movie
community it's devastating that he's
gone and i just hope that they handle it
with the respect that it deserves now
because of his passing there's gonna be
a whole host of characters that are
introduced to this movie including riri
williams and simon of course also need
to take up the mantle there's also the
introduction of neymar and he's gonna be
bringing atlantis with him so we're
gonna finally see how that compares to
dc's aquaman ryan coogler is still
behind the picture and after the success
of the first one i'm expecting this to
really knock it out of the park as well
and it's one of my most anticipated
films of the next couple of years next
we have the one hour halloween special
werewolf by night coming to disney plus
later this year starring gail garcia
bernal still not sure of an exact
release date for this one yet well
you're fired then however filming
wrapped in april and it definitely
sounds like want to keep an eye out for
we also have another disney plus special
hitting our screens this year in the
form of the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special once again with james
gunn at the helm with this special set
to take place between the events of thor
love and thunder and guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 i'm really looking forward
to seeing the return of this bunch of
chumps then we move to 2023 and we have
the marvel set for release based on the
characters captain marvel miss marvel
and monica rambo it is intended to be
the sequel the captain marvel and the
continuation of the disney plus series
miss marvel after that we have guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 scheduled to be
released in the united states on may the
5th 2023 we'll see the return of the
team alongside sylvester stallone and
will pulter will be entering the
franchise as adam warlock gonna be
amazing getting this character finally
involved in the mcu after the tease in
the post-credits scene of the last
guardians of the galaxy movie ant-man
and the wasp quantomania is scheduled to
be released in the united states on
february the 17th 2023 seeing the return
of peyton reed at the helm and paul rudd
as scott lang alongside the rest of the
cast returning however we also know
we'll be seeing the return of jonathan
majors as kang the conqueror after last
seeing him in loki as he who remains
bill murray has also been cast as an
undisclosed villain role which i can't
wait to find out more about after that
we're gonna be getting played penciled
in for a 2023 release this will be the
first time the character has come back
to the big screen since wesley snipes
played him in 2004's amazing film
underrated classic underrated gem blade
trinity oh yeah now mahashala ali will
be playing the character in the mcu
after debuting is a voice at the end of
the post credit scene in the eternals
2021 now slated for a 2024 release is
deadpool 3 which will officially see the
merc with the mouth introduced to the
mcu and yes it is disney and yes it will
officially be rated r in keeping with
the previous movies it's still in
development but ryan reynolds did
suggest in august 2021 that the movie
would start filming in 2022 we also know
that reynolds will reunite with free guy
and the adam project director sean levy
on the three cool as levy will be
directing i can't wait to see how the
character is brought into the mcu in
2024 we're also going to see the return
of the fantastic four after john
krasinski's illuminati cameo in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness he
hasn't been officially cast yet but i'm
sure everyone well most people are eager
to see him once more reprising the role
of reed richards he went out like a bowl
of wet spaghetti last time round and
it's only right that he gets to redeem
himself surely yeah give the guy another
chance captain america 4 is another
project confirmed to be in the works
with a possible 2024 release following
on from the falcon and the winter
soldier series on august 18 2021 it was
reported that anthony maggie had closed
the deal to star in the film it was also
reported that the film would begin
production in may twenty twenty two
seong chi 2 was also confirmed in
december 2021 although it doesn't have a
release date yet marvel studio have
already mapped out its phase 4 movies so
we can put a ring or 10 around that one
for now whilst nothing has been
confirmed it seems likely that both
simuli and aquafina will be in chongqi
too especially given the way the first
movie ended we also know that the 10
rings will return which means shia ling
will be back as well on november 29th
2021 amy pascal confirmed that sony
pictures and marvel studios were set to
begin development on a fourth spider-man
film she revealed that we can expect
more spider-man films starring tom
holland set within the marvel cinematic
universe on december 18th 2021 kevin
feige officially confirmed that a fourth
spider-man film which will be part of a
new trilogy was in active development
now we move on to the confirmed tv
series lined up over the next few years
starting with she-hulk attorney outlaw
this is scheduled to debut on disney
plus on august 17th 2022 and it will
consist of nine episodes concluding on
october 12th after receiving a bit bit
of stick online year for some dodgy cgi
in the first trailer i am actually
interested to see how she wreck comes
across once it's been released i am
groot the photo realistic animated
series is set to hit our screens later
this year on disney plus 2. with each
episode set to follow baby groot as he
grows up and goes on adventures with new
and unusual characters the official
artwork was released recently and has
been doing the rounds across the
internet showing baby groot chilling in
shades and headphones with a cocktail
and with james gunn serving as an
executive producer on the series feige
said he was excited about a planned
story for groot to return to his home
planet x now secret invasion is set to
explore a world in which the newly
introduced scrolls have begun
infiltrating earth already confirmed to
have cast emilia clarke olivia coleman
and kingsley benadire as the main
villain it's going to be exciting to see
how this is brought to the screen we're
also going to be getting back samuel l
jackson as nick fury and ben middleton
as talos aka everyone's favorite scroll
he was of course responsible for
introducing the scrolls into the wider
mcu and in my opinion mendelssohn gave a
brilliant performance it's gonna be
teaming back up with jackson's nick fury
once more and it'll surely pave the way
for more memorable moments in the
upcoming series while there's no trailer
yet for echo marvel studios did release
some art for the title character the
image was released with an announcement
that the show was currently in
production as of may 2022 and would drop
sometime in 2023 it will be interesting
to see how this one pans out after last
seeing her at the end of hawkeye having
apparently shot wilson fisk now
according to reports iron heart will
start filming in june 2022 rumors are
saying that riri iron heart williams
will make her live-action debut in black
panther wakanda forever on november 11th
and this means the series could possibly
hit streaming late november or sometime
in december after years of standing by
as the sidekick of tony stark rhodey aka
war machine is finally getting his
moment to shine don cheadle will star in
armor wars yet another upcoming
live-action series over on disney plus
possibly in 2023. now when what if
season 2 was first announced on disney
plus day on november 12th nothing
specific had been revealed about its
release date other than the season was
coming soon however executive producer
brad windenborn did stay back in august
2021 that they hope to release a new
season annually the second season of
loki was officially announced on july 14
2021 it scheduled the premiere on disney
plus during the disney's upfront 2022
presentation feige took to the stage to
talk about what the mcu has in store he
revealed that season 2 of loki will
begin production in the next few weeks
more importantly he confirmed the entire
main cast is coming back for the second
installment absolutely loved the first
season so can't wait for that one okay
so x-men 97 was announced on disney plus
day and this will see the return of the
1992 animated x-men series as far as we
know the plot will continue where the
original series left off with the
majority of the voice actors returning
to their roles as a huge fan of the
original series i used to watch it all
the time yet i can't wait to see this
one especially with that patrick stewart
entrance in the multiverse of madness he
of course came riding in in his yellow
hover chair and just getting the little
notes from that theme tune really made
that scene stand out for me it's gonna
be interesting to see how it connects to
multiverse of madness and whether that's
the same character or not but either way
i'm really hyped to see this series
return agatha house of harkness is
another upcoming disney plus spin-off
series following agatha harkness from
one division during disney plus day 2021
we heard that a new series called agatha
house of harkness was in development for
disney plus with catherine hahn set to
reprise her role as the title character
and there's also as of now an untitled
wakanda series confirmed with danny
guerrero as the only name attached so
far ryan coogler is said to be
developing the tv show set in the
kingdom of wakanda for disney plus
however no further details for the
upcoming spin-off series are currently
known at this point the animated series
spider-man freshman year is on its way
to disney plus and will take mcu fans
back to peter parker's early high school
days back in november of 2021 spider-man
freshman year was officially announced
during disney plus day according to
reports the series will follow a
freshman aged peter parker on his way to
becoming spider-man it will be based on
the character's iconic comic book roots
and marvel zombies is another one fans
have been clamoring for and we were
given a teaser for it in the what if
episode the blame for the series states
that it reimagines the marvel universe
as a new generation of heroes battle
against an ever-spreading zombie scourge
as a big zombie movie fan i'm very
interested to see how this one develops
right with all those confirmed releases
out of the way now we can delve deep
into the rumor mill and chuck some
projects out there that could be on the
horizon as always take these with a
pinch of salt but my guess is there will
be some definites in here i'm sure
alongside some surefire ralph boners so
will we be likely to see a nova movie in
the future
well yes and this one isn't so much of a
rumor anymore having recently been
announced that the moonlight writer will
be bringing the character into the mcu
at this point we don't know if nova will
be a series or movie but excitement is
already building up we of course had the
nova corps feature heavily in guardians
of the galaxy and i'm guessing that the
series is gonna build upon that there is
rumored to be a world war hulk project
in the works and is said to be a film
adaptation of the world war hulk graphic
novel while marvel has yet to confirm
the project the rumor mill is going wild
and it's such a massive story that i
hope it gets brought to the big screen
now several characters from marvel
comics thunderbolt are already in the
mcu and with val you know she went on a
bit of a recruiting spree and brought in
former captain america john walker
whilst renaming him u.s agent black
widow also revealed that elena bolova
works for her too and there was an
announcement by deadline recently that
the film is officially in production my
guess is that baron's emo's gonna be the
person leading them and will also get
the abomination and several other
characters that are slowly starting to
come in the marvel universe i'm looking
at you taskmaster after the cameo
appearances of the illuminati and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
were dispatched quicker than the bowl of
mom's spaghetti i really should stay
tight-lipped on this one but could we
potentially be seeing them return in a
project of their own with characters
such as reed richards professor x and
captain carter unveiled and destroyed in
the blink of an eye it would be great to
see them again and the possibility of
redeeming themselves now eternals 2 was
certainly set up towards the end of the
first movie we didn't get it confirmed
but you know there were teases towards
what would be happening in the future
that's mainly because the credits scene
revealed we could have a watermelon
sugar burst of star power in the form of
harry styles who showed up as eros to
every girl in my cinemas you know
delight they might have been screaming
for me but they were probably screaming
for him now he was joined by the
extremely you know it did look a bit
crap the cgi on pit the troll but he was
voiced by patton oswald who has made a
number of good performances in the
marvel universe already now they could
also well be joined by the black knight
as the post-credits scene sees our jon
snare sorry dane whitman going to touch
the ebony blade now we knew that it was
only a matter of time before mutants
were part of the mcu after seeing
patrick stewart appear as professor x
and doctor strange 2 every x-men fan is
theorizing how we will see the mutants
join the mcu as of yet there's nothing
concrete but we pretty much know it's
coming sooner or later now avengers end
game also teased the introduction of
neymar as okay mentioned that there were
underwater earthquakes off the coast of
africa you pretty much have it confirmed
that the villain of wakanda forever will
be neymar the submariner and this of
course ties back to their prior movie
the character has been rumored to be in
the film for well over a year now with
actor tina kuera rumored to be playing
the role rumors of a silver surfer
project could also be on the horizon
with stories of the character set to
appear in the nova project and or also
the fantastic four movie we last saw him
on the screen in 2007's fantastic four
the rise of the silver surfer and the
less said about that one the better now
daniel rpk has revealed that a 10-ring
series is in development at marvel
studios gathered that chongqi's sister
xia ling will be the series lead and
this could give room to expand on the
history of the rings and it also looks
like it could serve as a direct
follow-up to the first chongqi movie
next we have ghost rider and johnny
blaze has become somewhat of a cult
favorite over the years after the
depiction by nicholas cage fans are
always calling for more but will we see
a series for the character could it be
tied into the midnight suns who would be
taking up the role it's all just
speculation at this point but it would
be great to see the character return now
potential young avengers team members
have been sort of dropping in in the mcu
since as far back as ant-man we had
cassie lang of course appear in that
film and a lot of the mcu shows have
been centered around setting up these
characters this has led to characters
like kate bishop and of course billy and
tommy in one division potentially this
could all be building towards a young
avenger team in the future which i
definitely hope to see marvel studios is
potentially developing a project based
on the classic character nomad having
recently trademarked the phrase marvel
studios nomad alongside lots of terms
for other new projects this looks like
something that is more than likely also
on the horizon it could be introduced as
a spin-off from the falcon and the
winter soldier with possibly either
boogie or white russell's u.s agent
taking on the nomad persona now rumors
say that one of the shows currently in
development that marvel is yet to
announce is a secret warriors series
there was a recent animated movie that
also played on this too and the team
included quake and ms marvel with
squirrel girl america chavez patriot
inferno exile captain marvel and holler
also showing up this has got a great
cast of characters in it and potentially
we could be seeing something similar in
live action soon with the new season of
daredevil looking likely on disney plus
and that cameo appearance from charlie
cox as that really good brick catching
lawyer matt murdock in nowhere home fans
are desperate to see the return of this
character as part of the mcu it's only a
matter of time but will we see him up
against wilson fisk once more let's hope
so now there are a few characters from
the midnight suns that are popping up in
the mcu and that's kind of getting me
excited about their arrival there's
people like moonlight blade doctor
strange and also potentially ghost rider
and even your boy more bs yeah break
bring him in the mcu i say that happens
here which let's admit we all want to
see because the movie made more billion
dollars spikey's gonna see that and
realize it's more been time to bring him
into the franchise this would pop open
the multiverse again and it could spit
him out into the mcu which would be it'd
be the stuff of dreams guys now finally
apparently a wolverine anthology tv
series is reportedly in the works at
marvel studios very little is known
about this project at the moment but
early signs do indicate that it could be
a major part of marvel's mysterious
plans for bringing mutants into the mcu
reportedly opening in the 80s following
the weapon x storyline
we could potentially see each episode
cover a major part in the timeline
bringing us fully up to date but that's
all just speculation at this point it
sounds great in theory and i can't wait
to see if and how they will approach
this one and to find out who will be
taking up the iconic role and lastly is
wonder man which was just recently
announced first teased that in the
making of one division he is reportedly
going to be getting his own show very
soon anyway that finishes up the
confirmed and rumored slate of the
movies and shows in the works by marvel
studios and disney plus if we missed
something out or you've heard any of the
rumors then feel free to let us know in
the comments below also let us know
which of these you're looking forward to
the most and how you see things tying in
huge thank you to stephen for making his
own video and hopefully we'll get you
back doing more stuff like this in the
future if you want him to keep his job
hit the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
almost every day if you want some else
to watch we have a video on screen right
now just for you and without the way
thanks for clicking this we'll see you
next time take care peace